coming up over to you thank you so this
is trying to work with marco di way
Russell Ivan and Mohan who are I think
all in the room and it's going to appear
at itcs next year and before i'm going
to talk about what I exactly we mean
with this very very long title I'd like
to start by talking about why we care
about conditional lower bounds and
reductions in the first place so there
are a number of problems where progress
just kind of seems to installed and not
just not after a long line of results
but it's stalled in the 70s or even
before that for instance edit distance
we know how to do it in N squared but
that's essentially best we know and the
dynamic programming element for that is
attributed to Wagner and Fisher in in
the seventies another example is
threesome we know how to do it in N
squared but again it's essentially the
best that we know of I'm not quite sure
hard to credit this onto I didn't find
anything but at least the 70s as well
another example circuits out we can do
brute force I mean it's easy just try
all assignments and CF one of them
satisfies the circuit which is going to
be 2 to the N but again essentially the
best we know another example is three
points on a line you want to see if
there are three points that are
collinear again n squared is it's very
simple about best we know now what do
you and yet you see that these problems
they are very different from each other
that domain is different there are
geometric problems there are circuit
problems there run times of difference
there are exponential time there is poly
time the techniques are different that
we that are applied to them and even the
people who try to solve them are
disjoint sets so but all the texts seem
to have in common is that they that we
seem to be stuck so what we would like
to do is that we would like to prove
that they are hard that we cannot do
better but proven this unconditional
seems just out of reach with the
technology that we have today so instead
we'll try to settle for something less
ambitious we try at least explain a bit
some common principle
and this brings us to condition lower
bounds so it's an attempt to prove that
they are hard without actually proving
that they are hard namely we want to
relate the hardness of these problems
with reductions from one problem to the
other but not just any reductions with
reductions that respect the resources in
particular time that they need so we
want statements such as if 3some
requires n square time then 33 points on
the line requires n square times that's
the kind of statements that you want
here now if you think about where what
is the end goal of that what you kind of
want these two things first of all for
every problem that seems hard to be
somehow want to explain it the other one
is we don't want to assume too much so
we would ideally have one principle that
explains the hardness of all of these
problems and so what you have today is
not really that but we kind of have an
approximation to that nearly there are
three hypotheses that together explained
quite a lot the first one of these is at
the 3sum conjecture so the 3-sum problem
is you are given n integers that are not
too large let's say polynomial in N and
you want to find three that some 120 n
squared algorithm is not that hard to
come up with I mean something obvious
one the obvious one will be n cubed but
n square is also not at heart and we can
do slightly better we can save poly log
factors over N squared but you can check
your is that we cannot do better than
that in particular we cannot to end to
the 2 minus epsilon for a constant
epsilon so another problem another
contractor is the old-fashioned start
conjecture so all pair shortest part
you're given a way to direct the graph
and for every pair of vertices UV you
want to output the distance from you to
be and dynamic programming gives you and
cubed here and we can save a sub
polynomial factor over that but again
the conjecture is that we cannot do
enter the 3 minus epsilon for any
constant epsilon
and the third one of the ones that I'd
like to mention here is a strong
exponential time hypothesis so the case
that problem is you're given a KC
anything you want to find a satisfying
assignment brute force is 2 to the N
that's the obvious approach but we can
in fact do better we can do 2 to the 1
minus z + km so as long as ki as long as
k as a constant this is going to be
faster than 2 to the end it's 11 point
something to the N but you see that as
soon as K goes to infinity we are at two
to the N again essentially and the
conjecture is that we cannot do better
than that so in particular if you want
to solve it in 2 to the 1 minus SN then
there is some K so that for that K you
cannot solve it that first or in other
words as K goes to infinity you do need
to to the end time so with these three
conjectures or hypotheses you can
explain quite a lot so if you start with
those three there are problems that are
hard on the strong eth for instance
vector or technology and edit distance
there are problems that are hard on the
3some three points on the line is one of
them polygon containment and many of
them are geometric problems there are
problems that are hard assuming the all
pair shortest path conjecture negative
triangle is an example graph diameter or
another here is actually quite
interesting that many of those be the
hardest actually goes the other way
around as well which is not really true
for the other conjectures but we know
more we also know problems that are hard
on the subsets of of these conjectures
so siro vai triangle is hard on the both
3some and all pair shortest path you
might notice that this line here has a
different color and that's the reason
for that because it's the only reduction
on this picture that is a randomized now
to argue that zero of a triangle is hard
if threesome is hard we don't really
care if the reduction is randomized or
deterministic but you'll see I hope at
the end of the talk that in the context
of our target it very much matters if
it's
randomizer deterministic and there are
also problems that are hard under all of
them for instance single source flow and
triangle collection so now I outlined
two goals that we want earlier we want
to explain every problem and we want to
have one common principle so the
question now is so can we add other
problems into this picture and which
problems can we add and empty for the
other goal what we want is we want to
find this one principle and obvious
candidates are just one of those three
so this raises the question can we just
reduce them to each other for example if
you could reduce all pair shortest path
to CNF SAT then you could get away with
strong eth all together and explain all
this with just them two hypotheses and
that this talk in particular is about
those three directions can we show that
3some is hard on the strong ETH can we
show that all pair shortest path is
strong is hard on the strong eth and
what other problems can you show that
are hard on a strong eth so in
particularly in this talk we're going to
talk about them max flow min cost max
flow hitting set and them somewhat
larger class of problems that can be
described as first-order properties and
in particular the result is that we're
going to show reasons why this is not
possible so that's why the non
reducibility in the title comes from so
or in other words we want to show that
it's hard to show hardness ok so the
very first step in every lower bound is
we need to understand what we try to
rule out so this brings us to the
definition of a fine-grained reduction
so we are by no means the first to
formalize that and a fine-grained
reduction always calls from a problem l1
at some time t1 to a problem l2 at time
t2 and it's in some sense a touring
reduction that also respects the
resources that we have
particular we want to relate the time t1
to the time t2 so what do we do exactly
so let's say we want to compute l1 so we
have as input some X and we want to
decide if it's in the language and
output 0 1 but we don't do it directly
instead we're trying to do a reduction
so we'll do some computation after a
while we'll cut em we'll ask an Oracle
for l2 and then we do some more
computation and ask another instance to
an l2 Oracle and that second one might
be a larger instance or a smaller
instance it might depend on the answer
from the first and so on a V&V could do
any number of calls to dl to oracle so
so far i've just described the touring
reduction to you and i'm sure you are
not the first one to tell you what the
touring reduction is so what now for it
to be fine grained what we want is let's
say we have a somewhat fast algorithm
for l2 namely one that runs in t 2 to
the 1 minus delta for a constant Delta
what we want now is that this whole
thing takes T 1 to the 1 minus epsilon
also for a constant epsilon and this
epsilon might depend on Delta all we
need is that if Delta is a constant that
is greater than 0 then the epsilon also
has to be a constant that is greater
than 0 so for very reduction to satisfy
this we need two conditions one is the
reduction itself without the Oracle
calls should take at most t1 to the 1
minus epsilon and the other one is that
if we sum up the time that we spend in
the Oracle calls then that should also
be at most t1 to the 1 minus epsilon so
I hope you see that it's quite natural
quite natural form ization of a a
reduction that respects the resources
now the basic idea to show that there
are problems that are not strong eth art
is the following we want to say
something like that every strong eth
hard problem has property X but 3some
and all pair shortest part to not have
proper TX so if you can show something
like that then it's clear that 370
pressures but are not strong eth art so
now what is this property X and you've
seen a lot of hypotheses so far in this
talk and of course this probably ex-cons
within other hypotheses so so so our
goal was initially to reduce the number
of hypotheses and our solution is to
introduce a new one so our hypothesis
will call the non technics traum
exponential time hypothesis it's a
variation of the strong exponential time
hypothesis where we say that for every s
there is a k such that case that cannot
be solved in co non deterministic time 2
to the 1 minus SN so in other words
given unsatisfiable CNF i cannot prove
to you that it's unsatisfiable faster
then you could have just solved it by
blue force anyway now that non that
mystically case that is of course very
simple just give the satisfying
assignment and so what what is now the
property XD property x is that at least
one of non that basically or cone indeed
mystically the problem is how as hard as
deterministically so if we look at
problems that take time t to solve
deterministic allah then there are
basically four categories the ones were
non domestically we can solve it very
easier t to the 1 minus epsilon but
Conan domestically we also need tea time
T an example that is CNF SAT because
it's in NP so this T to the 10 sections
in fact even lochte and another exam
another class would be where non
domestically it's hard but colon
domestically it's easy an example is dnf
tautology
or there is also a category where it's
both non-domestic art and corn on
domestically heart so the example that I
came up with here is exact max at what I
mean SD decision problem if max if the
maximum number of clauses that we can
satisfy is exactly K so there you will
you cannot do it faster northern Italy
and cornered the risk because it
basically has a tautology and
satisfiability both building to them
couldn't really come up with something
more natural put in orders of course
also the other class were both non the
busy and colon domestically is easy and
we will show that 3some falls into that
class and our main result is that for
all problems that fall into this last
line they cannot be strong eth art so
they do not have this property x and
know that of course when i say that znf
set has property ex I mean assuming the
non-domestic strong exponential time
hypothesis so what we are so what we are
showing is the following assuming
non-domestic strong eth any problem that
is strong eth hardly time T on the
deterministic reductions so not
randomized reductions meaning here
either is hard not that mystically or is
hard-coded mystically or both
and so to prove that we look back at our
definition of a frank reintroduction and
let's say we start with an X that is in
the language and we do our reduction now
we call an Oracle several times some of
these calls are positive instances so
instances where that are in the language
l2 like here in blue and some of them
are going to be negative instances are
not not in the language l2 now if he
assumed that we have a fast non-tariff
mystic and corner domestic algorithm for
language l2 then we can plug that in
here so we can use non domestic pets to
prove that an inch that the instance is
in fact true in the first case and we
can also prove that it's false in the
second case and now this whole thing
here that the whole box is now a
laundered mystic algorithm for for l1
and because we assume that we can do it
none that we can do l2 and non-domestic
time T 2 to the 1 minus Delta and also
because it's a fine grained reduction
the reduction self does not take too
long so it means that if we can do l2
and time T 2 to the 1 minus Delta not
non deterministic the endodontic
ballistically we can now also do l1
non-deterministic Lee in time t1 to the
1 minus epsilon and the same argument
also gives us a cone on domestic
algorithm because if the input is an X
that is not in the language then
basically nothing has changed so okay
but note that we need this reduction
here to be deterministic because a cone
on a non domestic or colon domestic
algorithm does not use any randomness
anywhere so if he had a randomized
reduction here we would not get a non
domestic or corn or domestic algorithm
for l1 I will say more about that a bit
later
ok so the outline of this torque from
now is now a three points first the
first reaction of some of you might have
been why should I believe non-domestic
strong eth it seems somewhat unnatural
so the first action is going to be for
you namely we're going to show that if
it's false then it's going to imply
interesting new circuit lower bounds in
the second part we will look at problems
that have fast non-domestic and code
optimistic algorithms so in other words
problems that do not have proper TX and
that out therefore not strong eth hard
on the teton mystic reductions and in
the third part we going to be somewhat
more ambitious instead of looking at one
problem at a time and proving that it's
not strong eth hard we look at first
order graph properties and show that a
whole bunch of problems are not strong
at a chart ok so let's start with the
lower bound so there is a work by a
challenge or viola and miles that shows
that if strong eth is hard then circuit
lower bounds follow and the basic idea
of the proof is that you first show that
if you have a soft algorithm for circuit
class c you also get lower bounds for
the same circuit glossy and then you
look at circuit classes see that can be
written as a or of cns it and if you
have that then a fast algorithm for salt
can it implies lower bounds for circuit
classing well all we basically do is we
look at the proof or in particular ryans
proof or it and note that you don't need
to assume strong eth to be false it's
good enough to assume that non-domestic
strong eth is false in particular we
show that you don't need a circuit sort
algorithm for see you just need a cone
on domestic algorithm for that i'm not
going to show the actual proof for that
so that this goes into the theme of
satisfiability algorithms imply circuit
lower bounds because if you think about
it what does it say that strong eth is
false or
non-domestic strong eth response it's a
statement about the existence of an
algorithm so if you say that eth is
false then you're saying there is an
algorithm for 3 sot the dry runs in time
to to the epsilon n for every epsilon if
you say strong eth is false what you're
saying is there is an algorithm for CNF
SAT so that for every kk so this in time
to to the Delta n likewise if you say
that non-domestic eth is false which i
haven't defined before but he'll figure
it out what it means that means that
three tautology has a non domestic
algorithm of 2 to the epsilon n and
likewise if you say that non-domestic
strong eth is false you're saying there
is a non deterministic due to the Delta
and algorithm for K tautology so these
are statements about the existence of
satisfiability algorithms so what are
the actual lower bounds that we get them
so we have if we take the circuit class
sees and like linear size circuit or
linear size series parallel circuits
then you can write them as or of kc NFS
and so if you have a fast algorithm for
case Casey NFS or even a core
non-domestic 474 Casey and as you get
lower bounds for these classes I leave
it at somewhat vague got these lower
buns exactly are but the the important
part is that they are open since at
least the 70s and they will be very
interesting to prove those
and so I should actually note these
lower pounds these are things that we
expect to be true so these disconnection
from northern NC strong attached to
these lower bands is not an argument
that non-domestic strong eth is true
it's an argument that this proving it
might be hard okay so let's go to
problems that are not strong eth hard on
the debt elastic reductions so we're
going to talk about next flow where we
going to show that there isn't both the
non-domestic and the cord on the
domestic algorithm that runs in linear
time in the number of edges we're going
to look at min-cost max flow which
Bertie also a non domestic and corn on
domestic algorithm that is linear in the
number of edges we look at three
somewhere will show that you can do it
in n to the three half and that all pair
shortest paths which is going to be
entered 2.69 so let's start with the
easiest which is max flow so I'm sure
you're all familiar with the definition
you're looking for a flow from s to T
that so that there is not more flow on
edge than the capacity and you want to
maximize that and so we are interested
in decision a decision problem because
otherwise the distinction we know that
basement corner to listen doesn't really
make sense anyway so we ask is there a
flow of value at least K now there is an
algorithm that runs in times of MN and
the question is can we get it down all
the way 20 of em and I mean people
believe that this is possible there are
also cases where it is possible infra
dig for instance you can approximate it
in linear time if it's in on it's an
undirected graph and so what we could
possibly contribute in the realm of
conditional or imbalance is saying no
you cannot do that so we want to do
something like no you cannot do better
than n times n but the thing is there is
a 0 of M non-domestic algorithm for max
flow this is fairly simple right you
non-domestic the gas of low you check
that is indeed a fool
so that all the capacity constraints are
met info equals art flow and all that
stuff and it just check that it has the
correct value and that's not going to
take more than 0 of M time but you also
get a fast call non-domestic algorithm
to prove that there is no flow you just
get a cut of value at least k and again
checking that it's not going to take
more than linear time so what we have
shown is that max flow is not strong eth
hard for anything larger than 0 of them
so in particular for something M Squared
you cannot show it to be a strong eth
hard hundred thirty mystic reductions
assuming the Northern Mystics strong
exponential time hypothesis and if you
disagree and you think no no you can
come up with such a reduction then
you'll also have to prove lower bounds
for linearized circuits so let's go to a
slightly more complicated example so
main cost max flow here edges have
capacity as before but also a cost and
the cost is meant as a cost per unit
flow as and if you double the flow over
an edge you you pay double the cost and
the goal here is to find a max flow so
the search problem is find a max flow
that minimizes the cost or as a decision
problem you want to fight is there a
flow where the value is either more than
K or exactly K but the cost is at most
seen and the fastest algorithm runs in
quadratic time and I mean this is a
fairly general problem so max flow is a
special case it main cost perfect
bipartite matching is also special case
so again the non-domestic algorithm is
really simply just cast a flow and check
then the their Pateros also call on
genetic algorithm and it's based on
client cycle counseling algorithm namely
there is a lemma in the in the proof of
that algorithm that says that there is a
given flow there is a flow of the same
value but smaller cost if and only if
there is a negative cost cycle in the
residual graph but there but now we also
have a code on domestic at all of em
algorithm for finding negative cycles
which is which is quite simple namely it
follows from the bellman-ford algorithm
if you define a potential as a map from
nodes two reels such that d put forgiven
for huv the potential of me is at most
the potential of you plus the etch rate
then there is a negative weight cycle if
and only if there is no potential so so
this gives us the corner domestic
algorithm four min cost max flow namely
you first non deterministically guess
the main cost max log then you certify
that this in fact the max flow by just
guessing a cut as before and you certify
that this minimum cost by guessing a
potential in in the residual graph and
the whole thing is not is going to take
over so what have you shown we have
shown that main cost max flow is not
strong eth hard for anything larger than
all of them and again if you think that
you can find such a reduction and you
don't believe us then you'll also have
to think about circuit low pants for
linear circuits
okay so let's go to a 3some and all pair
shortest path so the the algorithm for
those are fairly simple and we call them
listing current algorithms so the basic
idea is as follows you take your
original problem and you embed it into a
problem that is somehow easier but one
that might have false positive solutions
now you knew use your non that net
non-determinism to non that basically
just guess all the false positives and
check that all of them are indeed a
false positive so they are a solution in
the easier problem but not in the
original problem and you also count the
number of solutions in the easy problems
that are mystically so if that's not
quite clear yet it should be clear once
we instantiated with threesome so what
was this recent problem again you're
given n integers and you want to find
three that summer 20 and we think of ms
polynomial in n so n n square this is
the simple algorithm and in fact if M is
small you can do it in Oh of you can do
it in all of em mainly with the
fast-food time-based azeri it fast
fourier based algorithm you can do it in
Oh of em so if M is in fact sub
quadratic you're already done you can do
it in faster than N squared domestically
and and there is also a fast non
deterministic algorithm for threesome
that's very simply just guess where the
three numbers are and you check that
they sum up to 0 so that's going to be a
sub linear if you have random access and
linear if you don't read so non
definition is easy the question is can
be also how can we prove that there are
no three numbers that sum up to 0 and we
do listen count so what we do is we not
that phonetically pick a prime p and now
we look at the problem modulo P so in
other questions the problem model PS are
there three numbers that sum up to a
month
people of P and let P be the number of
solutions that the instance has modulo P
which we call so not that basically
guess now we know that basically guess t
triples of numbers and we check that all
all of them they sum up to 0 modulo P
but they do not some up 20 model or
nothing so these are the we check that
they are indeed false positives and and
as an extra step we count the number of
solutions modulo P and make sure that
this number is in fact equals 2t so how
long does this whole thing take not as
basically guessing T trippers and
checking that they sum up to 0 modulo P
takes x 0 of T we just go through them
and check all of them and counting the
number of solutions of a threesome
instance modulo P can be done in ofp
with phosphor you transform it specially
the same algorithm as the same fast
Fourier transform algorithm as before
also works in this modulo P case I'm not
actually going to show how it works but
just believe me that you can do it in Oh
of P and now what I'm going to show you
is that you can take P roughly n to the
three half and then T is also going to
be roughly n to the three half so this
whole thing is going to take into the
three half at most so to show that to
show that the end to the three half is
enough so consider the first end to the
three half primes so the smallest one is
to the largest one is something around
em to the three halves times log in and
now look if you'd look at any three
numbers in your instance there some has
gone is a number between minus 3 m + + 3
m so it's going to have at most log of 3
mro of log and many prime factors this
means that on on average over all these
primes there can be at most n
cubed log and many so the sum over all
these primes in this range can sum up to
at most am sorry they appear at most n
cubed log in many times as prime factors
in the sum of three numbers so on
average because there are n to the three
halves many primes an average prime will
have n cubed over n to the three
hostages n to the three halves many
false positives and in particular if it
since you have non determinism if it
just not honestly guess the prime P that
has the fewest false positives it's
going to be a number that is less than M
to the three half and the number of
false positives is also less than n to
the three halves which completes
concludes the proof so I'd like to say a
little bit more okay so what have you
shown we have shown that 3some is not
strongly teach hard for anything larger
than n to the three halves so in
particular it's not hard for N squared
so under that mystic reductions is even
know the restorative so of course it's
what is absolutely possible is that a
3some actually takes times n to the
three halves and that it's strongly th
hard to prove improve over that I mean
we didn't rule out that what we ruled
out is that it's hard at n squared and
again if you don't believe us then
you'll have to find new lower bounds for
linear size series parallel circuits or
find a randomized reactor if you don't
believe us that there are no
deterministic reductions then you have
to do that or find the randomest
reduction that you can do that exactly
so there are many ways of disproving
that that made any sense what I'm
talking about yeah
it's not right it's not there's a right
right what what it is only ensuring the
something is not hard usually when just
solid start well the advantage is that
and every talk about conditional lower
bounds in the last few years on the open
problem slide the last slide is that it
would be really nice if we could show
that threesome is strong eth art and
what we are saying is maybe but it's
going to be a lot harder than you think
well yeah I mean you you can think of it
in many ways right or the other one is
that if you actually come up with that
reduction it's going to have even more
consequences that you than you thought
at the beginning so I'd like to say a
little bit more about this number n to
the three halves of this three halves
that's actually quite interesting number
41 a stem there is in fact a
fine-grained reduction from subset sum
at time 2 to the N half to three sum at
time n to the three half now so what
this means is that if you could improve
the colon domestic element for threesome
to 1.4 some end to the 1.4 something you
would also have shown that subset sum is
not strong eth hard at time 2 to the n
half which we don't know yet and the
other reason by entities we have is kind
of interesting is the decision tree
complexity of threesome is also in to
the three halves and so i cannot really
formally connect them i can just really
put it on the slide and say isn't that
spooky so so there is no real formal
connection here but it seems a weird
coincidence so let's talk about all
precious pearl so again the problem is
you're given a way to direct the graph
and you want to find the distance of
every pair UV
so and the floyd-warshall algorithm is
and cubes dynamic programming and what
we do is to instead of actually tackling
this problem directly we give a cone on
domestic algorithm for the zero weight
triangle problem and if you remember
this picture 0 a triangle also right
here so it's hard under all pair
shortest part so if you can show that
zero a triangle is not strong eth heart
then all pressure spot is also not
strong eth hard because fine-grained
reductions you can compose them but note
that we wouldn't get threesome for free
because that was a randomized reduction
so what is the zero a triangle problem
you're given a weighted graph and all
weights between minus Eminem and you
want to find a triangle so that their
weights sum up 2-0 now the trivial
algorithm is n cubed just go over all
triples and check if their sum is 0 and
yeah edit its and that's also the time
that is this all pair shortest path hard
at now the prop if we consider the
problem model of pee again where we just
take a prime p and take all the numbers
model on it turns out that you can do 0
a triangle modulo P and time all of P
times n to the Omega where Omega is the
matrix multiplication exponent i'll show
how to do that in a minute so the
listing count algorithm for for that is
again not that realistically 0 a
triangle very simpler guess the three
nodes check that they sum up 20 we're
only concerned with corn on domestic
algorithm for it so and the other one
goes as follows so you know that I see
we pick T and the prime P as before you
know that message league st triples of
vertices and you check that they sum up
to 0 modulo P the triangle defined by
these vertices and you check that they
do not some of 20 model or nothing and
you also count the number of solutions
modulo P and make sure that ste
so that your list that you guessed is
complete so how do you actually count
the number of solutions I'm model opine
so we've seen that four for 3some well
we haven't really seen but for threesome
the fast algorithm to do it modulo P as
fast Fourier transform we also know that
if the algorithm to find triangles in a
graph is matrix multiplication so to
find matrix multiplication to find
triangles that sum up 20 we'll just do
both at the same time namely the idea is
as follows we define a matrix so that
the entry IJ is the polynomial X to the
weight IJ modulo P and now we compute a
cubed and that's going to take time p
times n to the arm ago so enter the
omega because you're multiplying
matrices and times P because every
multiplication in our algorithm is
actually the multiplication of two
polynomials of degree at most P so it's
going to take over P now given a 3 & a
to the three we just check the diagonal
entries likelihood in when we try to
find triangles and we make we sum up the
coefficients in the diagonal of X to the
0 X to the P and X to the 2p so at X to
the 0 there should be all the number of
triangles I is in so that this sum is 0
and the coefficient of x to the P should
be the number of triangles that is in so
that the sum is P and X 0 to P the
sample B 2 period so these are all the
instances where the sum is 0 modulo P
note that it cannot go to 3p because we
started with numbers smaller than P
and at the similar argument as we did
for 3some barely count the number of
prime factors and so on gives us that
the number of false positives is going
to be something like n cubed over p
where p is the largest number so what we
now do is we know that mr. you guess all
the false positives in time Oh of T we
count the number of false positives in
times P to the M to the Omega and if we
pick P something like n to the 0.31 we
get that the maxis em to the 2.69 that's
after plugging in a concrete value for
Omega so so this has only been 0 a
triangle you haven't really done all
pair shortest part yet but if we just
use the fine-grained reduction from all
pair shortest path to zero a triangle we
get that we can do all pair shortest
part in time and to the 2.9 and you see
that we actually lose we lose something
in the exponent and you should not be
surprised by that because all pair
shortest part is a functional problem
its output is an n-by-n matrix 0 weight
triangle is a decision problem its
output this one bit so of course you
need to call your Oracle multiple times
otherwise how will you ever get n by n
matrix but the thing is we don't
actually need that what we are
interested in is in a non domestic
eloquent for all pair shortest path so
we can actually do a non domestic
production where we first guess the
correct solution and then just verify
that our guess was correct and if you do
that you can actually show that you also
get the same n to the two point six nine
and the exponent
okay so what have you shown we have
shown that all pair shortest part is not
strongly th hard at times n to the 2.69
plus epsilon on the debt domestic
reductions assuming non-domestic
strongly th and again if you disagree
and you think that you can come up with
one then you also have to think about
linear circuits so so what we've done so
far is we taken one problem we've shown
that it has an easy corner domestic
algorithm and we moved on to the next
but we want to do kind of more we want
to say like this is a huge class of
problems here and they are all not
strong at a chart and in attempt to do
that we looked at at a quantifier
structure of heart problems so many
problems that are strongly edge hard if
you write them in first ordinal notation
they kind of look similar for instance
the orthogonal vectors problem which is
hard at n squared is there is a vector
v1 there is a vector V 2 such that for
every eye in the universe and one of
them is zero likewise k dominating set
which is hard at n to the K is there are
vertices be bound to be K such that for
all vertices one of the khaid earlier
ones have an edge to it so again it
exists exists exists for all but there
are also problems interesting problems
with other quantity 5 structure right so
k click for instance is just there
exists a v12 VK so that they are all
connected but it turns out this one can
be solved in omega k third which is
considerably faster than the k
dominating set one or another
interesting problem is hitting said
we're where we want to find a set that
hits all other sets so there is a set H
such that for all set s there is a
overlap it's quantified structures
exists for all exists so again different
but this problem it seems to require n
squared but we don't we don't don't have
a proof that its strong eth hard to
improve over N squared and in fact what
we're gonna do should kind of show here
is that it's not going to be under the
drastic reductions assume another
transition and so on each device of the
world with Purdue so we can't assume
that we have two families of sets we
take a chart of the first family and s
out of the other family and then the X
is over like the universe there are now
over here okay that's one of the hitting
sets yeah extra be user yes yes yes yeah
absolutely i'm actually going to say
more about this i'm going to actually
show it in on that mexican corn of
domestic algorithm for that somewhat
later so the way we formalize that is we
look at first order formulas where we
have k quantifiers and we're going to
assume without loss of generality that
the first one is an existential one
because we can always negate and if a
problem is strong eth heart its negation
is also strong eth hard so we just can't
assume that the first one is next
stanchion and the problem that we look
at is model checking on graph so we are
given a graph g as input and we think of
it as a list of edges so in particular
we will be interested in the wrong time
as a function of M the number of edges
and we want to decide if the input graph
is a model for our formula and turns out
you can always do that in m to the K
minus 1 so the question that we ask is
for what problems is it strong eth hard
to improve over m to the k minus 1
second yes yes exactly the variables are
nodes yes but the input this size m
which is edges here and now there are
two classes of problems that are kind of
naturally defined by that one is growth
problems because I mean that's basically
the definition k dominating set is very
easily defined is very easily as first
candidate for the other one is also
problems on set systems where they but
where the input parameter m is the sum
of the sizes of your input sets that's
actually if you think about it a fairly
natural way of like size parameter for
sets right you give a list of elements
so in particular if you go back to
orthogonal vectors there are kind of two
ways of thinking of it you can think of
the input s01 vectors and then the input
will be number of vectors the input size
will be number of vectors but if you
think of these 01 vectors as sets then a
more natural way is to represent them as
elements and in which case the input
will be the number of ones and that
that's what we really consider that's
what the M is going to be here so our
results are as follows all problems that
are strong eth hard must have the
quantifier structure exists exists
exists exists for all in particular and
any other quantified structure is not
going to be strongly th hard at time M
to the K minus 1 so note that i'm not
saying that every such problem is strong
eth hurt so I mean the easy counter
example is exists exists exists for all
true that's very easy to check right and
it's not going to be strong with a chart
and so in particular what this means is
that if non-domestic strong eth is true
then there is no deterministic reduction
from a strong eth hard problem with this
quantifier structure to any problem with
a different quantifier structure
your second second class to cool it with
does not have the structure given up
faster than end to the cameras one any
problem that does not have the structure
either so I think the next item says it
so it is not clear of this slide I'll
answer again so what we are saying is
the following if it if the quantifier
structure is all existential you can do
it domestically an M to the K minus 1.5
right if it has more than one universal
quantifier you can do it for corner
domestically faster than M to the K
minus one and the same if it has one
universal quantifier but it's not at the
end then you can also do it faster call
on the tennis decline so in other words
the exists exists exists for all are the
only ones that can be strong at a chart
of course it's possible it that these
here are that the all exists are also
strong eth are just as a look at a lower
time so i'm going to do instead of proof
giving some proof such as to hitting set
as an example so what does heading said
again we have we want to find a set s
such that for all sets t there is at
least one overlap and it is an example
of having exactly one universal
quantifier but it's not at the end and
you're going to show that it i'm going
to show that it is linear all of em
non-deterministic lee namely what you do
is you guess the set s that hits all of
them and you just check all of other
sets that bear hit it but it's also all
of them caught on that realistically
namely for every set s you guess the set
that it does not hit which gives you
impairs answer you know it gives you n
pairs but you can check that in sorry
you can check that in all of em as well
so what we have shown is that you cannot
so be sure that hitting that is not
strong eth heart so in particularly
shown that there is no fine-grained
reduction from orthogonal vectors which
is strong eth hard to hit exit under not
as strong eth which is interesting
because there is actually a reduction
the other way you can reduce orthogonal
vectors sorry you can reduce hitting set
to orthogonal vectors and in fact
orthogonal vectors in some sense
complete problem for this class um there
might be talk in the next workshop that
dieter said a little bit more okay so
before i'm going to wrap it up I'd like
to say more about randomized reductions
so so far I've always stressed that it's
on the tectum mystic reductions and
there is a reason let's say we have a
randomized reduction where this block
here uses randomness but now what is
this is where we use Oracle's that use
non-domestic bits but we also use
randomness in our reduction now this
whole thing is not a non-deterministic
algorithm what it is instead is a Merlin
author algorithm so where the correct
proof is going to be accepted with high
probability which is the definition of
Merlin author so which and a fast Merlin
author algorithm for cns at does not
contradict the non-domestic strong
exponential time hypothesis so what is
the solution here and we could make a
new conjecture Merlin author strong eth
that that CF sat in fact does not have a
fast Merlin author algorithm and that's
exactly what we did but then we sent the
draft to Ryan and with her in half an
hour the answer came back the new it
does have a 2 to the n half algorithm so
there was a bad idea
mix once and then after there's a
complication yes yes yes so there is a
fast Martin author algorithm four shots
Oh Merlin are so strong eth is just
false not note that not all forms of
randomness are our problem so if you
have a zero error reduction that's still
okay so what what did you do instead
you'll have to bug Ryan about that he's
writing it up now also yeah okay so what
you do instead is we just come up with a
different hypothesis that does not
contradict the fact that there is a fast
learning author algorithm about them is
they're stronger than non-domestic
strong eth and what we came up with is
the non-uniform non-domestic strong
exponential time hypothesis so they get
longer and longer as you can see and the
conjecture here is that for every s
there is AK such the case that does not
have small non deterministic circuits so
they do not have 2 to the 1 minus s and
non deterministic circuits as far as we
know this hasn't been disproven yet but
note that we are really playing with
fire here because we cannot say that if
this is false then we have interesting
circuit lower bounds and we've already
got it wrong once right so but if this
is true then the reductive we can also
rule out reductions randomized
reductions would you expect
and also the deal helps and i'll go for
faster brought together classic time
already may exactly i mean i guess the
median for you to win expected and you
cannot do it in to end I mean it's
absolutely pop actually this is a dream
I would guess before working that this
would be debated I mean it's also
possible later it's possible there are
problems that have randomized reductions
but not a domestic reductions but in
fact but the thing is if we actually
find a problem where we can show that
it's not strong eth hard on the tetanus
to production but simultaneously has a
randomized reduction then this problem
would immediately become a very
interesting problem to study for the
randomization right so even in that case
there would still be like four questions
so to summarize what we've done so we've
introduced the non-domestic strong
exponential time hypothesis and we've
shown that if it is false then we get
new circuit level bands that will be
quite interesting but if it is true then
there are problems that are not strong
eth art so we have non reducibility
results and there in particular
interesting if you cut out the northern
the non-domestic strong eth middleman
you get statements such as if there is a
deterministic fine-grained reduction
from vector orthogonality hitting set
then we have new lower bounds for
linearized circuits which you you
wouldn't guess that like from the at the
beginning right there are a number of
open questions one is like the way we
dealt with randomized reduction is
really not ideal so there is room for
improvement there and also all the
problems that we discussed were poly
time problems I know it's a workshop of
an exponential time problem but and it
would be interesting to find a problem
in NP that that we can show that as fast
and not that echoed on domestic
algorithms or maybe that's the reason
why we couldn't find it so far maybe it
hard to show that it's hard to show
harness and of course this also includes
like parametrized results it would also
be interesting to find some parameters
results in yet another frame acquire it
would be interesting is if we could
somehow adapted to dynamic problems if
you can show none reducibility for
dynamic problems and also we it would be
interesting also to find consequences of
non deterministic eth all our is also a
non domestic strong eth and the last one
comes in the form of a fill-in-the-blank
statement like in grade school so fill
in the blanks every all pair shortest
path hard problem has property blank cns
thought and three some do not so it
would be really interesting if you could
find something like that so what this
property here is exactly is not clear I
mean there are a number of like
candidates you could play consider
space-time space trade-offs depth or I
mean parallelism or batch processing so
it's not clear what the property
actually is but what we would need to
think about this and what kind of
properties are maintained under some
notion of reduction so it's important
that you that you have property that
first of all distinguishes these
problems and second is maintained on the
reductions
questions so I actually have to the
first one is you're saying that subject
some have decision trees of size and
with em but you don't know what is the
connection to non deterministic or like
reputation why can't you guess the
decision tree and verify in linear time
and the size of the decision tree that
it's actually a decision tree and then
use it to it say I mean for 300 say n to
the three half steps decision tree yeah
no I'm sorry it's the depth of the tree
and the second one was your flow your me
your flow results stated them in terms
of linear programming parameters by like
the number of nonzero entries in the
matrix or something like that yeah you
can probably do something with linear
program we kind of avoided it because
there are all sorts of like how large
numbers are issues so that's why we kind
of voided that well for that the exams
that i showed it somewhat more clear-cut
yeah this is an interesting
I mean it's on the slide of open
problems and the way we don't know
anything I mean you would actually Union
somebody have to adopt the framework
because I mean it's not quite clear what
exactly non reducibility means in that
framework but yeah but it's definitely
an interesting question to think about
others leather let's break a copy but
let's we thank this weekend first